you know sometimes conservatives like
during the Tea Party era for instance
they love to waive that Gadsden flag
that's the yellow flag with the snake on
it it says don't tread on me
I like that flag it's an early
revolutionary flag but that that flag
kind of plays into the that liberal
premise a little bit I think in modern
times you know that don't tread on me
just leave me alone I'm not really gonna
engage in trying to change politics I
just want to be left alone and so it's
not my favorite flag I you know I've
still got it I've got it on my desk sand
things like that but the flag that I
prefer is one of the original American
flags it's called the Bedford flag and
it really shows you political stakes
it's a knight's arm coat of arms and
it's holding a sword and it says VIN
check out Maria Rey conquer or die
that's politics for you all right though
to quote cocaine Mitch McConnell the
winners go and make make laws and the
losers go home there's no if you lose
gracefully you'll get a nice write-up in
the New York Times maybe and you will
have no effect whatsoever progressivism
as we talked about yesterday is out to
destroy everything you cherish you are
the target okay no kumbaya no play play
nice on the left listen to the way that
Gretchen Whitmer of Michigan talks about
her conservative constituents some
conservative constituents came out the
other day they were protesting these
draconian and arbitrary lockdown orders
regular good old American patriots
waving the American flag whitmer I guess
she was looking at a different scene at
the Capitol than we all were all she
could see were Nazis in the Ku Klux Klan
decide our Capitol is not representative
of who we are again there were swastikas
and Confederate flags and nooses and
people with assault rifles and that's
the very you know that's a small group
of people when you think about the fact
that this is a state of almost 10
million people the vast majority of whom
are doing the right thing and that's why
we've seen our curve get pushed down
we've saved lives in the process and we
have to keep listening to the
epidemiologists and experts and not
listen to the partisan rhetoric or these
political rallies or
or tweets for that matter we have to
keep doing the right thing the next
right thing all of my opponents are
Nazis they're all Klansmen they're
racists they're terrible evil bigoted
people and we've got to tone down the
partisan rhetoric okay
we shouldn't listen to politicians we
should only listen to epidemiologists hi
I'm governor Gretchen Whitmer PhD MD is
she I don't know I don't think so I
don't think she's a doctor or an
epidemiologist no I mean it's
cartoonishly absurd language that she's
using none of which is true none of
which is true first of all we don't need
to only listen to the epidemiologists
we're a free people who govern ourselves
of course we need to engage in politics
we don't just export all of our politics
and outsource them to the exalted doctor
foul Qi I don't remember reading that in
the Constitution we govern ourselves and
it's only the demagogues right now who
were saying get politics out of this
kind of ironic it's only the political
demagogues are telling people to get
politics out of this but then what about
her claim she says that there were all
these Nazis and Ku Klux Klan at the
rally I mean I didn't go to the protest
in Michigan but I saw a lot of videos
from it I got to tell you I didn't see
any swastikas I didn't see any Ku Klux
Klan hoods we've got some video of it
let me tell you what if you've if you've
seen any going around on the internet if
you can listen to the chants here do you
hear any any people shouting in German
[Music]
you're under the water line I'm looking
around that scene I got to tell you I
don't see any Nazi flags I see a lot of
American flags I say that one actually
the one Nazi symbol that I see is
somebody depicting Gretchen Whitmer as
Hitler maybe that's what she's on she
got confused is but if you if you've got
a sign portraying your political
opponent as Hitler or Mussolini or
whatever evil guy you want to talk about
then you're not a pro-nazi protestor
you're an anti-nazi protester i other
than that otherwise I see some Gadsden
flags the flag we're just talking about
don't tread on me I see a lot of
American patriots who just don't want to
have their rights trampled by an
arbitrary government and yet she calls
all these people Nazis and racists
[Music]